Welcome to the new Hidden Brain Podcasts from NPR, I'm Shankar Vedantam. The Hidden Brain team has been working tirelessly for weeks and weeks on our first few episodes, and you can hear the first one on September 22nd. By listening, I guarantee that you will learn something new about yourself, and you're going to learn something new about the people around you. Now there's been one area of disagreement. My preference would be to keep everything under wraps until September 22nd, but my producers Cara and Maggie didn't agree with me.
欢迎收听来自NPR的全新播客节目《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。《隐藏的大脑》团队在过去几周里一直为我们的前几期节目夜以继日地工作，你可以在9月22日收听第一期节目。我向你保证，通过收听，你将学到关于自己的全新知识，也将学到关于你身边人的全新知识。现在，我们有一个意见不一的地方。我的倾向是将所有内容保密到9月22日，但我的制作人卡拉和玛吉并不同意我的看法。
Hey, Shonfer. Yeah, hi Maggie. So remember what we talked about with maybe doing like a preview for the listeners. I think we should just wait till September 22nd, Maggie. That's when we're launching. Uh, hey, Shankar. Shankar. What are you doing here? This is the men's room. We need a little preview.
嘿，尚费尔。哦，嗨，玛吉。所以，还记得我们谈过的，也许可以为听众做个预览之类的吗？我觉得我们应该等到9月22日，玛吉。那是我们正式上线的时间。呃，嘿，尚卡尔。尚卡尔。你在这里干什么？这是男洗手间。我们需要一点预览。
Just a little preview. Just a little preview. I want to be sad. A small amount. Just a couple of minutes. He looks mad. All right. Time to go home.
就一点预览。就一点预览。我想难过。一点点。就几分钟。他看起来很生气。好吧。是时候回家了。
Time to have some nice NPR. You're here. Something that would be stronger. What? Why are you in the back seat of my car? We want to talk a little bit more about the pre-final. I'm going home. We'll go home with you. You can talk to us about it too. No, no. We'll be on our side. No.
是时候听点美妙的NPR了。你在这儿。来点更有力的东西。什么？你为什么在我汽车的后座上？我们想再多聊聊最终预览版的事。我要回家。我们跟你一起回家。你也可以跟我们聊聊这个。不，不。我们会站在你这边。不。
Alright, Mackie, I give up. Woo! What do you want to play for them? I've been thinking about this a lot, and I think we should play Switch Tracking, because it's all about arguing, and we've been arguing here at Hidden Brain. I feel like it's perfect. Alright, I suppose so. One pattern in human behavior that we're going to discuss on this podcast is called Switch Tracking. And as soon as you hear about it, you'll notice it in so many conversations.
好吧，玛吉，我投降。哇！你想给他们播放什么？我对此思考了很多，我认为我们应该播放“轨道切换”，因为这完全关乎争论，而我们最近在《隐藏的大脑》里也一直在争论。我觉得这太完美了。好吧，我想也是。我们将在本期播客中讨论的人类行为模式之一被称为“轨道切换”。而且只要你一听说它，你就会在许多对话中注意到它。
Here, let's have Sheila Hien explain. So switch tracking is a pattern in feedback conversations that is so common that it's instantly recognizable. That's Sheila Hien. Along with Douglas Stone, Sheila recently wrote a book called Thanks for the Feedback, the Science and Art of Receiving Feedback Well. One of that chapter focuses on Switch Tracking, which she describes as when… Someone gives you feedback, and your reactions to that feedback changes the subject. She uses a scene from the 2006 TV series Lucky Louis to illustrate the concept. Louis and his wife Kim are getting ready for a child-free romantic weekend. And Louis has just bought Kim some red roses.
来吧，让希拉·海恩来解释一下。所以，轨道切换是反馈对话中一种非常普遍的模式，以至于它具有极高的辨识度。那是希拉·海恩。与道格拉斯·斯通一起，希拉最近合著了一本名为《感谢反馈：接受反馈的科学与艺术》的书。其中一章重点讲述了“轨道切换”，她将其描述为……当有人给你你并不想要的反馈时，你对该反馈的反应转移了话题。她用2006年电视剧《幸运路易》中的一个场景来阐释这个概念。路易和他的妻子金正准备度过一个没有孩子的浪漫周末。路易刚刚给金买了一些红玫瑰。
So a switch track is that place where the track is going along and then there is a switch. And depending on which way the switch is turned, the train will glide smoothly onto a second track or stay on the first track. So what's happening is a conversation starts. Listen, try not to take this the wrong way, okay? But if we're gonna be married for the next 30 years, I need you to know that red roses are not my thing. The first person stays on their own track,
所以，轨道切换就是那个轨道正在延伸，然后出现了一个转辙器的地方。根据转辙器转向的方向，火车将平稳地滑入第二条轨道，或者停留在第一条轨道上。所以发生的情况是，对话开始了。听着，尽量别把这话听岔了，好吗？但是如果我们要在接下来的30年里做夫妻，我需要你知道红玫瑰不是我的菜。第一个人停留在他们自己的轨道上，
the second person actually smoothly switches to a different topic, which is their own reaction to the feedback, and often the feedback that they have themselves for the first person. Okay, well, um, can I critique how you just told me that? And they just get further and further apart, right? And they don't even realize that they're going in different directions.
而第二个人实际上平稳地切换到了一个不同的主题，也就是他们自己对反馈的反应，并且通常是他们自己对第一个人的反馈。好吧，那个，嗯，我可以对你刚才那样对我说话的方式提出批评吗？然后他们越走越远，对吧？而且他们甚至没有意识到他们正在走向不同的方向。
I've told you before that I don't like red roses. Remember? I just think that you should have thanked me for the flowers first, and then said the thing about the roses. There are really two topics on the table, right? Kim's topic is you don't listen to me, and Louis's topic is you don't appreciate me. Still, it's a gift.
我以前告诉过你我不喜欢红玫瑰。记得吗？我只是觉得你应该先为花谢谢我，然后再说玫瑰的事。桌面上其实有两个主题，对吧？金的主题是你根本不听我说话，而路易的主题是你根本不感激我。不过，这毕竟是一份礼物。
So I guess I don't think it matters what it is. You should still thank me, right? Yeah, but you see, I don't necessarily think I should thank you for giving me something that I've specifically told you that I don't like. That's all. And each of them is hearing the whole conversation through the lens of their own topic. So in this case, they're not even really
所以我想我不在乎它是什么。你还是应该谢谢我，对吧？是的，但你看，我不认为我一定应该谢谢你送给我一件我明确告诉过我不喜欢的东西。就这样。他们每个人都在通过自己主题的镜头来听完整场对话。所以在这种情况下，他们甚至没有真正
realizing that there are two topics on the table, I think. What I find fascinating, Sheila, is that the person who is receiving the feedback initially doesn't realize that they're switching tracks, that they don't actually, it's not a conscious decision to say, I recognize this person is giving me feedback, I'm uncomfortable with this topic, I am strategically going to change the conversation to something else. It's not happening at that level, is it? It's not happening at that level at all, and what's interesting is, so for the person doing the switch tracking, you're just thinking, well, that's actually not the most important thing that we need to talk about.
意识到桌上有两个主题，我认为。希拉，我觉得最迷人的是，最初接受反馈的那个人并没有意识到他们在切换轨道，他们实际上并不是，这不是一个有意识的决定，去说“我认出这个人正在给我反馈，我对这个话题感到不舒服，我要策略性地把对话改变到别的事情上”。它不是在那个层面发生的，对吧？它根本不是在那个层面发生的，有趣的是，对于进行轨道切换的人来说，你只是在想，嗯，其实那并不是我们需要谈论的最重要的事情。
What we need to talk about is your problem. The person who started the conversation sometimes actually does realize that the other person is changing the topic, and they view it as making excuses or distracting or trying to take us off on a tangent and to the second person it's not a tangent at all. It's the most important thing going on. So that's what the fight then becomes about. So we're both aware we're having an argument and the real argument is about what's the most important topic here between us. What happens when both people feel that topic is so much more important than the other person's topic that neither is willing to give way.
我们需要谈论的是你的问题。开启对话的那个人有时确实会意识到另一个人正在改变话题，他们认为这是在找借口、转移注意力，或者试图把我们带到题外话上去，而对第二个人来说，这根本不是题外话。这是正在发生的最重要的事情。所以这就是后来争论的焦点。所以我们双方都知道我们在争吵，而真正的争论是关于我们之间哪个才是最重要的话题。当双方都觉得对方的主题远不如自己的主题重要，以至于谁都不愿意退让时，会发生什么？
Um, your song. Hidden Brain. A conversation about life's unseen patterns. Subscribe now in iTunes or wherever you listen to your podcast. You can also find us on the NPR-1 app. The first episode, as I have said many times, is coming on September 22. Discover what's inside your hidden brain. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嗯，你的歌。《隐藏的大脑》。关于生活不为人知模式的对话。现在就在iTunes或你收听播客的任何地方订阅。你也可以在NPR-1应用程序上找到我们。正如我多次说过的那样，第一集将于9月22日播出。探索你隐藏的大脑里面有什么。这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。